a robotic lawn mower and rug beer is a
vending machine that dispenses beer when
it's tackled vauce Kevin here this is
mind
blow your wallet may eventually be
inside your hand the veins in your hand
are completely unique to you and are a
more secure identifier than fingerprints
Palm vein scanners are already being
used to identify customers at AG TMS and
could eventually be used to identify you
in a database so that buying a pack of
gum for instance would simply require a
scan of your hand tether is a system
that lets you edit 3D virtual objects in
midair created by two students at MIT it
uses an iPad and a motion tracked glove
and allows for virtual object
manipulation with your hand in real time
it even allows for a collaboration
between a pair of editors Utah State
University is climbing up walls with a
vacuum the personal vacuum assisted
climber or PAC system uses two large
suction pads with tubes running to a
vacuum and a pair of foot stirups
attached to the pads with cables assist
climbing and a major selling point is
that it works on any surface 1,000lb
wine rack Transformer this humanoid
robot is learning language like a baby
researchers are looking to quantify the
transition from baby Babble to
recognizable word forms by studying the
process of learning the names of simple
shapes and colors good green but this
one isn't green this one's
[Music]
blue meanwhile learning to swim is swo
the swimming humanoid robot it's being
used to analyze water resistance and
propulsion something that's difficult to
do with human swimmers due to a lack of
repeatability in the tests and it was
created with a 3D body scan of a real
person measuring facial expressions and
using an animated Avatar is now possible
with a standard webcam the KO University
group that developed the system say it
could be used by CG animation hobbyists
or also to represent people in web
dialog systems So eventually you could
literally be your own anime character
say when you're Skyping with friends Hey
look it's Mickey Mouse on Mercury
potentially keeping your shoe ss clean
in the future is this suction mat the
idea is to eliminate dirt from being
carried into buildings on the bottom of
shoes a sensor detects a person
approaching turns on the cleaner and it
suctions away the dirt finally Lou
schwartzberg moving art is a collection
of incredible hd nature videos like
[Music]
this I'm going to leave you with a
walking table and as all always thanks
for
[Music]
watching